white house correspondent peter ducey
has the story he's at the white house
for us this evening hi peter
good evening john adding supreme court
justices
to the high court or putting term limits
on the justices
are on the table as a presidential
commission
examines the impact of changes that
could erase
the current conservative majority and
they are going to report back here
within 180 days
before the election democrats really
didn't want to go there
senator harris should democrats pack the
court the supreme court
and this was as close as biden got i've
already spoken on
i'm not a fan of court packing but now
that they're in the white house the
administration is asking 36 experts to
study the effect of expanding the
supreme court
potentially filling new seats with
liberal justices something biden didn't
like as a senator in 1983.
he said he thought that court packing
was a bonehead idea when fdr
tried it it was a bonehead idea
it was a terrible terrible mistake to
make
so why ask a panel now to go and see if
it is a good idea
well first he's the panel is being asked
to do a number of
take a number of steps including the
pros and cons on exactly that issue
but they will also be looking at the
court's role in the constitutional
system
the length of service and turnover of
justice on the court justices on the
court
the membership and size of the court
republican senator ben sasse writes what
the president doesn't have is the
courage to come out and flatly tell
the radical left that he's not going to
pack the supreme court
liberal justice stephen breyer is
warning this could politicize the court
as activists call on him to retire
demand justice rights this can't wait
much longer we can't assume democrats
will have control of the senate for the
next two years
what does the president think about that
he believes that's a decision justice
breyer will make
when it he decides it's time to no
longer serve on the supreme court the
white house is also now addressing the
texas governor's calls to shut down a
shelter for migrant children in san
antonio
there were complaints that were filed
with state agencies and those complaints
articulated very specific allegations
about sexual assault on minors at this
freeman center currently we have
no basis for his call to shut down the
freemen the san antonio freeman coliseum
as an intake site
but we will of course we take these uh
this these allegations seriously
and they will be investigated the feds
are now spending 60 million dollars
a week to shelter migrant children
according to the washington post
but talking about his new budget the
president didn't mention the border or
immigration he did talk about another
threat though
it makes major investments in the fight
against climate change
the white house's coordinator for the
southwest border
is on her way out ambassador roberta
jacobson now says her plan was always
going to be to leave
after the first 100 days and officials
here are saying the vice president
kamala harris will continue overseeing
a whole of government approach to
dealing with immigration which is
different than what they had been saying
that
she was just in charge of diplomacy with
central american countries and
that's why she hasn't been in the border
yet john ambassador jacobson's tenure
didn't last
long peter ducey for us at the white
house tonight peter thank you